we've talked about this before very
beautiful talented woman
you're very physical though and you're
you're sort of not afraid just just grab
people and things and too much it's too
much yeah I mean there was this woman I
was just at the hair salon mm-hmm she
had this little dog it was kind of an
ugly dog it was like a Maltese it looked
real janky and but she took like this
little curly hair and she must have
straightened with a flatiron
and then she put one ponytail holder and
then another ponytail holder so it kind
of looked like a water ox yeah and it
was like I just walked up to her I was
like this dog is making me so mad I'm
gonna punch it it's so cute
and then she looked at me she wasn't
from here so she didn't understand
anything I was saying yeah you listen
but you don't have to be from here to be
shocked when someone comes up because I
want to punch your dog you know that's
not a hey you might me what are you not
from LA or something it's just like but
that's how you are like feel like loving
though yeah I know no no well you were
less we talked once about you with
babies and sometimes you said oh my god
I love babies so much and and then you
start to say this crazy stuff I Ed Helms
just I just did it - ed Helms
ed Helms just had a baby and she's all
eyes and she kind of looks like Tweety
Bird she's so beautiful and I was like
just talking to him and I was like I see
Canady show me this photo and I was like
I'm gonna punch that baby she's so bad
when you say I want to punch you you
make me so mad it means that love it
I never say like if I am like mad at you
I never go I just don't mad at you right
like I never do that no that's like mad
made you like it yeah so let's add at
you right now okay okay so but you know
that's weird cuz if I went around saying
that I would get in trouble if I went
around and was like oh that woman is
really attractive and I went up to her
an outside jackpot you okay well that's
confusing you're sending really
dangerous confusing signals you're very
physical
you're very physical with with you with
your boyfriend Sam Rockwell's they're
these paparazzi pictures of you it looks
like you're just hitting him on the back
and then there's another one I think
what you're like hitting him on the
bottom and that's you not even realizing
that you're being photo ID occurred it
can I tell you but he was getting the
stupid not that the Oscars stupid it's
so exciting I mean right then he was
getting that Oscar symbol thing on the
thing saying Sam Rockwell he won an
Oscar he won an Oscar she didn't want to
beat somebody when they win an Oscar I
don't know I just couldn't believe he'd
won like I was so happy I mean it truly
comes from a good place
yes I wouldn't walk up to some I'm not a
very angry physical I don't know I don't
think you're angry person at all but you
are physical like how important is it to
you I know you're in a committed
relationship how let's just say you
weren't how important is it for you if
you were dating someone that they're
like physical that way do you like guys
it's a good handshake I mean that's with
everybody like you know if you ever like
shook someone's hand and it's like
flaccid yes give me your hand like this
shake like oh oh yeah yeah yeah but then
there's the flipside of that because I
like to shake a hand but sometimes a guy
will get like into a tall guy a big guy
like yourself yeah with me they'll start
if I go hey no like oh you got a firm
handshake and then they start to go and
then you're like you pay you win I win
I'm tapping out you're stronger than
they I get it I get it
did I just do that right now no you
didn't you were wonderful I was trying
to
I was just in Ireland yeah Belfast yes
um Game of Thrones I would punch every
one of them I'm telling you I love those
guys too so oh you like them yeah doing
a little I'm not allowed to say what it
was but it was really fun it was right
got a cat out of the bag yeah you sort
of got me trouble yeah but anyway the
important thing is it's not a problem
it's not a problem at all
lose your job
[Applause]
let's change topics